i heard a question which was
can we have decimals in fractions i take
it what the question was is something
like this
uh 0.2
divided by okay so can we write that
can we write that yes now the answer is
yes and no i'll tell you what let me try
and justify
the answer is yes because look i just
did
i just did write it and you guys all
know what that means it's not ambiguous
it's uh it's zero divided by a hundred
so to be um
0.00 zero zero two
or two over a thousand right so you all
do know what that means however
i don't think it's a good idea i don't
think it's a good idea
decimals and fractions they're kind of
different ways of looking at the same
thing
two different angles on the same
perspective
now uh the same object now when you do
this you're kind of trying to mishmash
both of them
right uh and mixing those up in general
is a bad idea it's a little like
speaking broken english
um my parents when they moved this
country their english wasn't the
greatest so they'd speak half
in english it's what i learned what i
grew up with but then they'd get to a
word and they're like i don't know what
this word is in your language i'll just
say it in my language and then it was
sort of a mishmash of communication
and it was confusing in general okay
just like this kind of is
okay now here not that big a deal but i
think it's a really bad habit
to get into later on it will become a
big deal
i could write some stuff up on the board
which would be kind of meaningless to
you
um but where this mixing up thing
actually does make it mean something
different
possibly something wrong so i said yes
you can write it because
look i can but i'm going to ask you not
to write decimals and fractions together
okay